[Music]
and don't save me news submitted by
wafers or cookies yeah we love wafers
yeah I love a wafer
I like wafer stupid cookie that is not a
cookie there's no dough in that baby
shine Oh wafer is a [ __ ] sandwich of
toast
that doesn't even make English is a way
for a cookie to steve-o wafers
absolutely cookie
good I'll fight literally anybody - it's
just a sad no really I'm ready to fight
there are three people with vaginas on
that side oh really you want to say it
to my face [ __ ] you wanna come
say it to my facebook
do I come over there get my [ __ ] what
do I get my [ __ ] ass me right now
alright you want to put your [ __ ]
knuckles in my mouth right now [ __ ] are
you you watch me cry huh are you gonna
sit in the hospital right now
[Laughter]
Hey what is that wait wait for like
waffle part hey Joan is that Jay Joe Joe
Joe sir
we're moving on just reverse Bobby Lee I
think Oh what is it a man who tried to
drown himself is suing the police and
lifeguard who saved him what yeah like
hey let me kill myself [ __ ] if you're
trying to leave this world why do you
[ __ ] is going on if he comes to me I'll
take them to the forest you can't joke
about the forest anymore engineer yeah
wait what happened in for suicide force
we can't joke about the LP well we're
not your bean
oh it's not a suicide floor is it's a
target practice Forrest I got tied to
the trees shoot him what's the what's
the just thing to do then yeah if he's
suing you for saving him do you just
take him back to the pool and drown him
yeah make it a three point three what's
that yeah yeah cuz we gonna make it
happen yeah so just make it fair so if
you refuse at the river
these life look a bit and then you jump
in and then you go and when you get
there he's like I'm trying to die and I
borrow my band and I swim back No do you
have money how do you lose your wallet
okay so you jack him before he does
no I ask him like cuz it's like you
don't need it you know oh can I have it
right can I ask you would you try can I
have it yeah yeah all right to be honest
with you guys this headline here is a
little misleading because it's gonna be
you got me [ __ ] I don't think I've ever
been I'm live in a clickbait video yeah
true this feels weird
enjoy it enjoyable how does it feel to
be in the frame and God alright so the
reason why I'm saying it's misleading is
because this man so he suffers from
bipolar disorder he was working at this
pool like taking pH level is cleaning
the pool whatever but he told the people
the people that hired him I don't know
how to swim right he was fine the first
few days and then after he started
getting crazy like he started yelling at
some girl he like yank some wristband
off of her and just being kind of
aggressive so at that point police were
called to calm him down and then he just
like walking around the pool speaking
him because he's from pulled in so he's
like speaking in Polish and it just
seemed like he kind of lost his marbles
of it and so police didn't want to
approach him because he was being really
crazy
yeah crazy you've been cooperating as he
was walking up in his client plant
wooden shoes I like David what is what
is polish hey you know what what has
pork this guy who wears wooden shoes
or bad whatever have paulin I think of
people with last names I end with the SK
I and in violence are huge
Pulaski's of us equal clocks because a
box key oh yeah here's SK is it I can't
pronounce
oh it's a bunch of a map see they don't
you Danish people are the only ones that
wear wooden shoes mean is Danish that
that it's Danish clogs that's like it's
our old and they have like jamming
that's just [ __ ] good from Denmark
right you're also Danish if you're a
pastry hey hey how about that legend
exact comedy Amy the legends of dad
comedy some of the greatest dad comedy
jokes ever told all right well I need
some clarification the only thing I know
about polish is the hot dog at Costco
and that's all we need to know okay gals
I see some other food [ __ ] I'm gonna cut
it i'ma cut it right there Lebowski so
the reason let me get back to why I
think this is click bTW so he ends up
walking into the swimming pool himself
and so you just wait he gave himself
into the water you mean like he gave
himself into the ocean coming and he
knows he can't swim and then I'm gonna
show you guys he was trying to do a
baptism on his own okay he tried to be
baptized ready
Feist is that the police that this is
him he's practicing lifeguard you [ __ ]
this I'm out sick [ __ ] it's only four
feet the whole way [ __ ]
they're all like what the [ __ ] is you
doing you did an elevator three three
years did he hold his breath for that
long or did he go up and go wow so low
there's a Mexican line you know I don't
think we're asking the right questions
who the [ __ ] hired a bipolar lifeguard
yeah who hires the lifeguard was like
hey listen I can't swim
he's like a pulse and that should be a
job requirement was that all they do
yeah I think they do a hell of a lot
more than me too I don't provide for
their family yeah thank you I do love
just simplifying on top of it all they
[ __ ] do is devastating how hard is
that [ __ ] it's just a [ __ ]
maintenance guy for chlorine in the
water
we're palest NGOs like CEO not geo yeah
it was you it was just and said that oh
that's true I never what the [ __ ] h2o
technician yeah is what he is I'm also a
freelancing entrepreneur know what that
means I don't have a job so humans the
pool attendant right so he walks in he
is suing the police department and a
lifeguard because wait which side is he
suing the which part of his personality
I don't know the boy who's doing the bad
one
yeah he's suing them is because he is
claiming that they let him die like
clinically died before rescuing him and
so he's saying like why did you just
leave me in there and then the [ __ ] he
was doing down there yeah these are the
rebuttal that is saying that well we
were trying to protect everyone else's
lives because you're being erratic and
like what if you pulled them down and
like try to harm like they'd end up
drowning or something so that's the
reason why the cops ooh for that [ __ ]
[ __ ] floaty thing aside before I win
the pool in Kerry welcome
yeah and I'm trying to test if he could
like breathe in the water like this guy
does all the time for no reason I will
say of all the times of our house of all
the times I forgot to use that excuse
like we were trying to secure the safety
of everyone around I might do the guys
in the [ __ ] water even if you're
trying to punch somebody in waters like
you can't do much like I've heard that
excuse a lot from cops okay I don't know
what your jobs like so cool but we're
trying to protect everyone at the pool
around me like come on member I think a
better excuse would have been man it's
cold and I had all my clothes on I'm not
jumping in there full that's more like
it
the club's actually stopped the
lifeguard from jumping in and saving him
so that's why he's saying like you know
I could have been saved sooner if you
had a military [ __ ] Marine dude he
could have saved them well did he get
stuck down there or is he saying he
tried to comes up right did he did he
tell them like I'm gonna kill myself
see that's the thing like I don't really
know cuz they're saying that you're just
killing in pool I just think that he was
trying to practice underwater walking
and he failed and he's like hey help me
I never made it all the way across
mm-hmm I could never make it we try to
have races every time we get a Airbnb
underwater race who can go all the way
to the end and back with one row buddy
will never grow up
nobody can what do you mean grow up
nobody can make it all the way to and
from no one
it's impossible yeah that's all you can
add back oh I haven't done that is you
to slow down there yeah I thought you
made just one way I'll say I think it's
anything in the fastest kind of plan
right take the fast kind of plan Aquaman
George you're like who was it Jesse
Owens or somebody Michael felt I could
do it on a backyard pool but not like
that but who's the fastest speed walk of
the planet all your time I walk in
that's what I'm saying
underwater walking the the bottom you
just need a free diver
those are holding breath like five
minute all that's true and then there's
those other ones that hold stones and
they're like they're like whoa Ronda
Rousey trained for a fight like in
Hawaiian they do that
there's a Filipino guy I could do for
five minutes he could hold a friend who
put down it no more and he does
[Laughter]
like when you get to a certain point the
pressure from above keeps you down so
you don't flow oh yeah yeah how do you
breathe that's not what I'm like
fascinated no they just they're usually
there there so you know we can't breathe
underwater no I know we can't be the mom
but I'm saying how does he like lasts
for five minutes because he trained
himself over the years you never watched
free diving videos not there's people
they died down and they're walking and
breakdancing for like the entire length
of the video for like three to five
minutes because they're there literally
if I don't know about the breakdancing
part literally it's just quiet where
like it's equal is like an equilibrium
part where you just don't float or you
go down but if you go past it it'll suck
you all the way down oh so it's like
some crazy shits weird how do you get
out of there there's a rope and then you
go off and then they have to release
like certain levels of oxygen dizzy yeah
so here's uh here's this Polish dude 23
years old American military he looks
like a youtuber
yeah yes are you saying that he has more
than $100,000 in medical bills and that
why cuz he got sold she actually had
like cardiac arrest he was he stopped
breathing like I did why did we buy I
mean that's kind of obvious what's gonna
happen like if you walk into a pool and
you hold your breath he was in his right
state of mind because before that he was
like he was claiming the lifeguard tower
and I blowing his whistle like crazy and
then he threw his phone into the shallow
end and then dived in twice to get it
you should have been an actor how did
the cop know that he's not just having a
tantrum by bipolar people make the best
actor but cops aren't responsible for
that you can't sue a cop for not saving
you though that doesn't work like that
does it yeah yeah what's this guy think
he's American yeah come on oh well this
is in Virginia
oh oh well there you go he's jellying
polish in Virginia yeah
so he came to the US on a summer program
oh so he forgot he was in America and
it's not the cops responsibility it's
like the paramedics respond to save you
should sue the paramedics
oh I don't know that exact just don't
seal
[Music]